who were the first one to ever really
juice me up
mark maron wow it's kind of funny
he doesn't juice anyone up well he and i
have had some weird moments in the past
because
i think more perception than anything
it's like just we're
very different kind of human beings yeah
very different styles of human beings
but when i was an open micr mark
pulled me aside and he said and i i
and i told him he and i had like a
dispute at one point in time
and uh i said i gave you so much slack
for so long i was nice to you for so
long because you were so nice to me
when i started out but you're such a
[ __ ] and he's like you're right
i was taking some steroids from my back
you know really
well you know because i had not really
not wear growth no no
no because i have pain yeah like the you
know uh i hurt my back
and sometimes they give you steroids for
inflammation and uh
it was so funny because i was kind of i
was getting cranky and i didn't know
what it was and i think it was that
but like i tried i you know like i was
taking those and i got a traeger
and my producer texts me so like you're
on steroids and you got a traeger you
turned into joe
you know back to the tumeric guy as he's
walking away he's like
oh yeah if you're gonna get the turmeric
make sure you get it with black pepper
in it or it won't activate now
right there that does not make you go
like that sounds like [ __ ] to me a
little bit
am i that big of a sucker that you think
i would believe that where's the science
on that that
sounds like a couple of vitamin hustlers
sitting over a mound of wholesale
turmeric
with a bunch of empty gel caps one guy
going i don't know man
i don't think we can move this just like
this
it's just a spice i think we got we got
to add something
yeah like what boss i don't know why
it's a 30s movie
i don't know maybe another spice yeah
like
what maybe pepper yeah keep talking
maybe maybe we say it activates it holy
[ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] million dollar idea
right there let's load up these gel caps
maybe rogan will move him on his podcast
i mean i know marin won't do it he's
more of a stamps.com squarespace guy
but rogan's sort of an old-school
supplement slinger
and i know i'm going to get a little
flack for that comments
i know there might be a minor pile on on
twitter of the
monoculture of free thinkers but i can
take it
[Music]